this 2015 in Star Wars is having an
amazing year the new film coming out and
a new game from dice creators of
battlefield they are going to be making
star wars battlefront they sure are and
they just recently announced yet what 20
be 20 space battles yeah it's pretty
cool fire squadron 20 be 20 then I 10 of
those 20 are humans the rest are
titanfall creep AI BOTS itch fly like
[ __ ] they actually fly really badly
and you can kill them real easily but
there any worth one point Peter the
humans are worth three points and you
know those transport ships that spawn
randomly and take 45 seconds to cross
the map there worked when T what use
your hands 20 points first one to 200
wins x brings vs type why there's three
different line atop Tatooine and I
played on solace and it's pretty good
fun so how does that feel how did the
controls actually feel this game it
feels good I think for one main the one
main reason I really like the idea of
this is because I was like a big chopper
pilot by Patsy's Vietnam I like doing
the area stop in faculty or two in
desert combat whatnot and the sort of
the problem you get a lot of the time is
that you're spending a lot of time
hugging like getting up and then hugging
the earth and doing strafing runs in
this one you're basically the entire sky
is kind of your playground there's
nothing happy there's incidental stuff
happening on the ground but it's not
really your focus so you were
essentially dog fighting like old style
you know Red Baron flying through the
air trying to pick some of the ad and
that's cool because that other stuff can
be distracting and 13 thing is that
sometimes if you get down that low of
somebody's on your back there's like you
know elements of the environments of
terrain and of buildings that you can
use to your advantage like sort of D
Quran and get under there's also like
bonus items ended a fixture ship and and
get more shields and there's this other
one that lets you be the Millennium
Falcon which I did which was awesome
super bowl p but yeah but i like about
it is you sort of free to pick around in
the sky and you're getting situations
where you're fighting someone who's like
behind you who's been behind or like
four of you end up tackling one person
every like it it feels different to the
you know out to the way i'm sure the the
TIE fighters next wings feel when you're
in like just a big norm
mode game these games were like pretty
short they were like sub 15 minutes it
was around 15 minutes each and it kind
of felt like your ad for yourself yeah I
mean this one I didn't really matter
mine because it's not it's not a it
wasn't a mode where you're trying to you
know we chew a unified goal of like
we're trying to get that face or we're
trying to like take over this much land
mass where you really really try to yeah
you're kind of if you're kind of doing
its kind of one-on-one while everyone
else is doing one-on-one because you
know you're you're like battling one
person and like trying to be ready this
team at the end right shirt one team
versus another team yeah but it's 2015 a
video games we've it if you lose they're
gonna give you a shitload of points
don't worry about I love points it kind
of feels that way it's like it it
doesn't feel like a mode I think you
would play along it feels like kind of
an interesting you know like when you
when you're going in one of the things I
like about like which I think we've lost
a lot of when you used to play that
games like on earth Ramona or like
Quaker stuff is that sometimes you get
like a really stupid map but it was kind
of fun because it was like oh change of
pace great like polyploid cleanser I
feel like a lot of mud spare game's
levels so long and so this is so much
like I don't know almost like
self-serious like this felt more like
just kind of a little jaunt around and
it was competitive in the like I was
looking at the score and like trying to
be like all right right to way and
they've got four to win so if I just
don't die I'm helping the team so I was
still doing that but it didn't yet it
didn't have that pressure of trying to
communicate properly with people maybe
I'm just a jerk maybe it was like
playing on my own it's probably the real
reason I see you not a service fee and
why are you now looking forward to that
yeah i'm looking forward to battlefront
sort of anyway because i like the idea
of like i like Battlefield games but
being able to lift that you know there's
using of real world yeah just get attack
against a lift and being able to use
weird types of ships that don't work the
way humans once doing weird guns and
weird places that's that appears to me
and I think like having a weird mode in
there like this one I enjoy playing it I
think that's I think that's cool I think
there's you know there's a lot of the
new variety they can do in this one and
how much variety you know saying the
fact that this is a game doesn't have
any single player
opponent to it is something else like
what do you think about that I know
you're a big fan of the single-player
aspect of these types of get well maybe
I battlefield I know like a Star Wars
property Ava wants to top a single
player I think it shortens to me the way
that you're talking about sort of like
competing as a team but also not really
having much agency as a member of said
team that yeah it sort of helped the
greater cause in any way other than just
not dying when things get rough that to
me is also sort of indicative of the
issue where you're playing is really
iconic star wars levels as sort of this
a no-name and like yeah you can pick up
Darth Vader you can play as Luke
Skywalker but I'm concerned that you're
not actually going to feel like you are
a pivotal person inside of these parts I
think from what I played this felt like
a very disposable battle it doesn't feel
like I was part of this moment and
that's what I'm worried about I picked
up an icon and then I was the Millennium
Falcon and it was like rude but I never
felt like I just like gotten the freebie
it didn't feel like I really was very in
pocket so I was kind of okay that is
somebody who's not like maybe my
expectations are like relatively
mediocre but yeah I think to that point
you were right it doesn't it didn't feel
like this grandiose battle it felt like
it felt like you were so different yeah
yeah where I'm just like on ppppp you
and and stuff like that if you'd like to
go fast you'd like to have controller
removability it sounds like the TIE
fighter is someone to go but you need a
little help aiming and getting down
enemy ships maybe you want the x-wing
with the hundreds of years exactly
Peter's got it exactly right there's
difference in the ships and you've also
got this weird thing where you can like
basically put your shields up or have
your speed go up on your ships out of
like any dangerous sowwie like changing
where the energy is going and that's
cool too so that you know it's like a
symmetrical but they're you know they've
got the pros and cons interesting I
don't know I mean I'm really excited for
battlefront especially for the aerial
combat stuff so you've got me a little
intrigued I still was there a single
player stuff but if I can have fun dog
fighting that might be enough for me
I'll get a lot more games com content on
the way so stay tuned to gamespot com
you